l'art sur les ti une exposition d'art
contemporain installée dans un golf
c'est ce que vous propose l'association
art egolf sur le site de bêtement à
poissy une première édition pour faire
se rencontrer ce sport et l'art à
l'origine du projet il ya ma passion le
golf dans lequel j'ai envie de te voilà
de continuer à évoluer et
je suis aussi très sensible à l'art sous
toutes ses formes et donc j'ai eu l'idée
nous envie de réunir ces deux
disciplines
sur mes lieux de patients deux objectifs
rendre l'art accessible aux habitants de
la grande couronne et attirer les femmes
vers la discipline elles sont moitié
moins nombreuses à la pratiquer pour ce
faire à côté en plus de l'exposition des
initiations golfique sont proposés aux
visiteurs
c'est gratuit c'est ouvert il suffit de
réserver et on a deux heures
d'initiation au golf alors où ça plaît
et tant mieux on qu'on accroche si on
continue ou pas mais ça aurait été une
belle expérience fait revenir l'art sur
un lieu autre qu un lieu d'exposition
classique une idée qui a séduit les
artistes ils sont seize à participer à
cette initiative le golfe
ainsi elle est vraiment quelque chose
que je ne connaissais pas a comme je
connais le l'arcouade le voilà donc
c'est je trouvais le lien très bien si
ça pouvait marcher aussi dans l'autre
sens que les personnes qui elles sont
plus habitués aux boeufs viennent
regarder il ya des golfeurs il ya des
artistes qui viennent voir les
sculptures et nous mêmes on est
intéressés on va aller faire un petit
tour sur le parcours c'est une belle
association quand on est parti sur un
parcours on a un peu d etat d et c'est
un peu comme dans la sculpture de la
réalisation d'une sculpture c'est des
étapes c'est un objectif sur place une
quarantaine d'oeuvres sont exposées
jusqu'au dimanche 17 avril initiation et
compétition sur inscription plus
d'informations sur le site du golf